all right let's see here
how to go about this in an organized way
wow my other two sons got covid to they
don't live with me there in college
car purchase fell through yesterday is my
wife trying to find another one
Christopher Lee don't have a car right now
I'm like a 50 year old with no car have the
answer for the $200
no just how big is a computer just use vm's
on your machine
yeah do what I'm doing
this is this is the cheapest way hands down
and it'll get you all the training you need
you don't need to set up everything
I guess if you answer what I mean
and why would you set up a VM server for
driving youget baby to raspberry pies in a
case for two hundred bucks
just spend a little bit more money on your
current for computer and put the CPUs on
there and use vagrant that's that's my
current position so I'm doing right now
actually which is a great segue into the
day's stream
again of the purpose of this is primarily to
give me a community severe enough fast
anytime I want and go to practice and
resetting it up also to play around Santa Fe
storage classes so that I can check
monitoring volume ounce and a combine this
with monitoring outside of outside
activities and inside of Curry's and sending
alerts I think that's that's those are all
that the corps needs of the of our job right
now
at work so we've been talking about alerts a
lot lately
an observer ability and visit you and
visibility into your cluster and Sada
excetera excetera
so get right to it I only have one more work
or no to join
I want to spend a little bit of time for
generating search so that I can SSH
between systems and the reason for that is
because
I want to play around with the notion about
I honestly I think that's something I
probably want to put in my cluster is
another what I want to put the ability to
use any of the control planes is launch
Point without
without
password login using certifications as a
safe search to get to any of my nodes have a
I just something that I personally am going
to put into my architectural decisions
anytime I'm deploying a cluster anytime and
appointed cluster it includes you know
search Publix medicated SSH access from any
of the control planes to any of the nodes so
that we can quickly get on a node and and
take care of it and if that means on
occasion putting
you're adding a side server to do that kind
of thing but for the most part they can't
replace it always be able to do that they
should be able to to get to them to Russell
Sage a new thing I just discovered call VM.
Provision file copy of file over and I want
to do that by generating an SSH key and
I am going to go ahead and just
do that this way
I mean if somebody wanted to change your
keys I don't need to do that again this is
just a test server so I don't mind having
those search built into my thing
I normally would never saved public and
private search here
if you know I mean I guess I could generate
them dynamically but then they can't be
provisioned
I don't think your Vigor to file can
generate stuff
I mean I suppose I control plan I can do the
problem I have is
yeah
I mean I can put it into the provision
script the provision scripts kind of
cheating though right
the first purpose is for just kind of all
things to all people
I try to decide is ansible to provision can
reduce cluster from bare from Bare Bones
service
instead of this provision yeah
I am that's where I was headed originally
but I have such a small demand for this
provisioning that I kind of want to make it
within the single within a single of a grand
file you know
I definitely think there's value in doing
that I think the long-term might need to
learn how to do answer with bruising like
that but and it was definitely a better
suited for this kind of thing
well when it comes to vagrant
I have two options are I can try to generate
the certificates during the provisioning
process and copy them over
or I can hardly code some public and private
server pair for this deployment that's
understanding that this is just a a test
they were already making Liberties were
dropping that do you know doing all kinds of
things that you would never ever do on an
actual production installation like you
would never just dropped the firewall on
disable system VSC Lennox and some like that
so where are you taking liberties with this
to make it just work in a local environment
as if it was a MINI Coupe on steroids you
know and actual thing
and to that effect I think Kim cancel
commands on the Sonos yeah
that is exactly what I'm hitting as you know
because I I would run the one command on as
root on the control at I was just about to
write some good information and things says
hey if the same as control then do this if
the host name isn't then do that to you know
and I can't even be sure that it's going to
provision any of those systems in a
particular order
and it's not like you have a different stage
right it's not like you have provisioning
and then another provisioning right I guess
you could is this or these
have a question so are these
are are the are these if I have a separate
can pick up provision is it guarantees that
happened after the other one I have a
feeling it is
I have a feeling it is I have one step in
and you have another provision step
if it is then we're fine
they were fine we can have that first
division step say yeah if it doesn't if it
is then we could say
we say post for vision and that would be
all the stuff image of the cell
so if the host name
equals troll
I can see if it in this case we only have
one
where's your SSH stuff
here's a drink man generator bacterium in it
I'm not going to be doing that this
difference I mean if you wanted to do that
if you wanted to like it the whole cluster
of yeah
this particular this particular thing that
I'm doing right now sets up all the stuff
necessary to start scheme ATM and it from
command line but it allows those steps to be
to my house because it's designed for
training right
but that that is really annoying those steps
are really annoying So eventually you're
right I would want to make another one that
totally stands up the whole cluster like
entirely if it says of the storage class and
everything you know
and I don't know how to do
that your joint commands you'd have to
I mean if you set up an FS first and get
that going you can set up the joint command
you can that's one way we could do it we can
actually set up an offense that I'm a good
cuz I kind of want to do it anyway I have to
set up and if there's any way you can set up
NFS through vagrant
and then you could store it in the share
drive and then everybody could just know it
was there
wish we kind of need to do that anyway you
know
let's do that that'll actually that'll
actually make short work of the S8 setup
if we do that at first because they'll be
sharing the same file system and we can just
do that
and I need to set up an FS anyway so
it's very important yeah
yeah if one side the fastest setup all we
have to do is just spit the output to
standard temp directory in NFS and then go
on to the note and doing on there
we just have to make sure it doesn't in
order serious with nothing with it multiple
Provisions right so
it does hit Dusty did you get your ass to
work
provision
no I did you get your future bigger than
work
all right Parma Homestead yeah
and put that down here
I think you're pretty manifest volume should
happen before all the community stuff
because this is this is a provisioning this
system right
we need to do this isn't limited to NFS like
independent of everything else
yeah the magic if this magic is annoying for
sure
you know what's going on
this stuff is okay with attic storage cost
what is your thing we need to do we need to
do so there's
c n i c s i and
he c r i
oh I know
Ruby's pretty good I don't remember if I am
it's been fun
you didn't do files you can copy files over
I don't think we need to come over I think
if we create an FS over there which we need
to do then everything would be shared
I actually needI actually need to do that
alright I actually think I have this up
right now so we're going to focus on
manifest right now like quick I did this
once but I'm not very good doing it I do
think I'm going to have to set up an FS
quickly as of Cora Cora Cora skill
very important and again I I don't I don't
do it all the time so this is another thing
to practice
what's that is mind control and dammit maram
if I do last night I had four complete
Annihilation wins in a row with Nature's
actually to still get it published to the
turbo guide on how to do it
Fujitsu so so crazy the secret is not
getting boots
they were up so we don't have a big enough
I don't know how to set up in a peso I'm
going to go ahead and do this I kind of wish
you could you could do like stages I wish
maker and had stages
so you can like say vagrant up face one
bigger tub face to you know I mean
that would be so cool
sometimes you might not want to bring up I
can probably do it inside for some
directories
you seem like here are just the machines
again now and then here is the machine plus
like if you want to test different parts of
the process
now you can just coming out those entire
sections I guess of the provisioning once
you get there
where you can you can put a good put you're
such a Revival in Persian script
and I mean so we can do this is just say
Unisys you say the same I'm so glad hostname
worked it was just so easy I don't know why
we were missing Alyssa
I got to do Elden ring guys can take over
everybody sign not mine though
just code inspection tool where'd you find
that
if you had traffic to your boo tcpdump for
kubernetes
holyshit holyshit
haha
Circle Bar C O my God that's cool
yeah goes into my second brain
I'm so thankful that it for later Credit in
FS volume
I think I'm a boy alright so let's just go
ahead and provision this thing
are you up it's going to take a while I had
I took it down yesterday because
I should probably start using bigger at
Holtz instead of destroying my whole thing
how my kids had it has a Shins
oh really
did you just put it in a file store with the
push right
are using it or is it just a basic cuz it is
just a just a technique doesn't have to be
good kid it is not the best for this
rsync
yeah that's what I do oh you're linking
directly to the file name
oh shit oh shit does that work
fuck you don't even need to make an app for
that
so you just need to you just need to take
the time stamp and then open up because
that's a pwa like that
that's like a 30-minute pwa oh my God
did you make it to mobile a is a ptb
you can make a progressive web app that just
opens that you seriously you can't make a
progressive web app all it does is a
redirect
it's just as it creates a crazy new number
and read her accident yeah
there's that you could make all the pwa does
is redirected to a new thing
there's a reason yeah so are you listening
to the cookie
yeah sorry this service at Nanny's name is a
cookie and then redirect I know you just
every time you go to it it gives you the
news that the problem is
I promise he has it well searching is not
that problematic because you have already
has surging
no it doesn't know I was just your cookies
God damn that's Bryant that's really really
that is very brilliant
so it looks like it looks like the
PostScript is guaranteed to act and run
after the other ship which is very nice
6 make something soon yeah search is just a
link right yeah
yeah I just put like a button in a button go
to it simple for the wind I mean why am I
cross the streams is already a system for
storing knowledge you know so source
and then you can when you get to your foot
when you get to your computer you can do the
right thing you know Andre base or whatever
you need to do that's the biggest downside
of using getting GitHub is all the rebasing
eventually you're going to have to do it
you know I'm over at I'm over 1000 gets
right now and it's it's it's stuff to browse
it but it's not meant to be browse just
meant to be searched
most recent that yeah yeah
yeah I mean that whole thing yeah
eventually I want to have it so that that is
stuff is saved when you save is it but every
time you add an extra bit to the process you
complicated so I can't because it work
like if you update the Manifest every time
you create a news that or if you render
everything is HTML every time you do it both
of those are both things that I've thought
about doing right
I think the solution there is to put a hook
I think hooks are the way to go on this is a
real solid examples when it hook makes sense
like so because if you could use your simple
thing
you know this simple little kid if you make
an idea and if you have a hook on GitHub you
can Auto publish that is a web page
and United touch anything
he tried to touch any any change to the any
change to that repo would trigger I
rear-ended her that the only problem with
that is this year's that gets really really
huge yeah you just out of here is Ezra s
really huge you might have to pay for
processing power but it's like going to mold
the cost would be like totally minimal
yam cuz I'm saying yeah we kind of actions I
meant that I meant that when I said I'm
going to get it back to us
the trigger I get her the action and render
it
give him some of the cost of that I did not
know that you fucking kidding me
if used to get of action and you're tied and
you use use use GitHub pages
or even everfi which automatically just does
anything that's ever been changed to get hub
no netlify doesn't do that actually
now because Nana has a hook it wouldn't work
it at these going to pages and interesting
ever know not what this not something like
this
oh yeah you better get of action and Run
Road boom
I need to figure out where to figure out how
to standardize the location of the renters I
think we need will it has to be supposed to
be so I can dock they let you identify that
now
if we had set in that the root at the root
of our zettelkasten if we had a director
called doc
then we could render everything in there
most recent that issue 2
yeah totally does because you could just
rendering
yeah you can put the NN you can just put
that as a piece of data on your gate and you
just fetch it and you naked to your latest
right just URL request
yeah absolutely well that's the thing that
I've started to go down that rabbit hole and
then like oh because I I want to do it in a
way that's consistent so everybody can do
the same way
yeah as soon as we start adding as soon as
if she's already too much of that stuff
I kind of want to put a. Zet aura.
Meta or a. Norrell and I mean
I start my start wanting to put files in the
root is so that you like a manifest file the
reason I
the reason I haven't gone down that path yet
is cuz I know it's going to suck me into the
knowledge exchange for itself again because
as soon as you have that as soon as you have
that you have
because now I have to do is be able to share
everything with everybody else so the most
recent file thing was already a part of
manifest so the Manifest is supposed to be
the Manifest is supposed to be a single file
at the route to that has everything and it
shows when it updated and Wyatt updated and
then other people can follow the Manifest
and if it to see which things manifested now
you can follow other people's battles
yeah go run with that I mean if you want to
run with that but whatever we do I really
want it to be super duper hyper clean
API standard because then we can share as
that's the thing you know it was kind of
idea and rendering Alyssa we were starting
to enter into that space
I can take a verb a search engine when
should you get this already
yeah well here's the thing if I mean if we
get it to render to get a pages right and we
include in the render the Manifest file then
people can access URLs and we don't have to
use get for that we can use we can use the
base URL to follow people
yes I'm trying to say yes I already and I've
got a lot of work done on it already like
there's one file called Subs those are all
that there's a follow there's a there's a
there's a root level file file called follow
follow you follow you said to is it when it
says here you blacklisted so you can
collaborate with other people into boxes
people assess all in my in my keg stuff but
yeah I have fun with it I mean we can
massage it into his standard I would look
we're very close the reason that I stopped
working on Peg and by the way not picking B
on on The Keg was because of that we
discovered is that thing and it's been about
a year now right and I really feel like it's
mature and it's solid and just the standard
just to read me in this kind of thing works
for me
I guess I'm absolutely that's the whole
point it is the reason I did it this simply
it was so that you could use it anywhere you
can store and get repo and you don't even
need to get repo right strictly speaking you
don't need to get repo you could just do
something else but to get rid of those are
nice because of the generation of the
metadata so if you if you if you have
actions to generate the metadata I mean your
golden golden now we can like in a post a
link to anybody else's things and you can
have like a URL to the source and you can
have a URL to the render and the render
would be and then we have to ask a question
do we include the readme.md files with the
index HTML files in the render if we want to
make it web accessible everyone or just keep
it on on get
I think we should probably just keep it on
yet personally because because get people
can get clone I didn't get cloning is
probably the most the lowest hanging fruit
in terms of like something to somebody's
thing it does however store all of it right
and the difference between that and doing
the Manifest by the way I was talking is it
you could actually coat it so that
if somebody wants to follow another person
they don't have to get all of their stuff
they could get the most recent changes to
the Manifest files and only download those
things basically and if we do it that way
we're kind of simplifying our own get in his
innocence because that way you can fall
people you can you can follow some people
say look I only want to know if they've had
any changes and other people can say no I
wanted if the Manifest every time and see
any changes that have happened in the whole
thing
yeah yeah I mean if you're if you're this is
all part of that the knowledge exchange for
his stuff is that'll just kind of kind of
came in and derailed me because it worked
and I had enough to get through it but those
are the next steps is their hands down their
people been asking me because I hit a
thousand that's now so yes let's talk about
it
let's see here alrighty
so we got our Provisions stuff going to go
ahead and go out to the
see if
we're going to go out to the let's what day
can we do that on I know sometime sometime
when things are just random we can talk
about that I really
I really want to I really want to put cake
back in the front all I can guess is just
sharing zettelkasten Intellicast in or just
as little as just a notch notice so there is
overlap there and then we can in a go with
that that's why I put them as individual
read me and there's a fire in the San Jose
that you can use the data. Yamel file as
well and yours at all if you want to if you
want to have structured data and then you
have distributed flat file database
there's no fucking Bitcoin whatever
yeah oh yeah me too I'm probably weekend
maybe Sunday afternoon and God knows I'm not
going anywhere we have a car
I can't believe you don't have a car I feel
like I'm 20 again vagrant
vagrant SSH into the control
we are going to set up an FS over here and I
am going to start from scratch
actually have a live on this how much RAM do
I have
is a 16 your check though
yeah I allocated to dig around to each thing
so 246 right now I'm pretty I'm under pretty
tight Ram pressure I don't think I can do
much more than what I'm doing right now
so yeah like I'm using 10-gig
a 15 gig and that's that's with three
provision vm's at 2 gave each
something I learned about me I'm just
recently this last week go from talking to
people to know more than me is
the ram is the one thing that's going to
limit the number of Verso machines you have
more than anything else you can
over-provision CPU but you cannot
over-provision Ram
it actually makes me wonder if how much RAM
I can add to this particular machine
because I I think I think I might jack up
the round a lot so that I can have multiple
the ends more than just three beings running
is Hebrew like a 4 gigahertz
gaming system i7 are we go 8 cores at 4.7
GHz is freeze pretty fast see if you
Governor 28 yeah tricked out with rims
of course you would
My Bologna but it's not great and chunky
chunky I don't I don't know if I want to do
that but
has Metallica man looks so cool
it's only call Bosch top so much tell me
about it on the stream pretty cool huh
it's called Bass Shop has been reinvented in
in Rust and go and there's like one of her
what everybody likes
awesome flutter my quick thoughts on flutter
or
you should do it if you're doing mobile
native app development you need to learn it
Isaiah 7 yep yes
this is The Fantasticks it's impossible to
please games pretty well when I don't have
all my DMs on Twitter with 32GB to CPU
Ravenna running yesterday and it was not
good while streaming
and who is not good it was definitely not
good
I forgot to go on stage with just going to
give me a second here
start the stage
there's a station just cords people come in
and talk to me too but mostly I need to
focus
so I know and I complain about Papa's but
I'm going to change anytime soon because I
just need to get shit done and I want to be
able to play games then it just works right
now until it doesn't it's not it's not
annoying enough to throw out
I just want to reimage myI just want to
reimage my system I really don't I do not
ready for you
n f s n f s it is
I have an entire thing on an FS a whole Lab
I did on it so I'm going to go read my notes
on it
I thought I did
I make Labs every time I learn something and
make a laugh about it so has all my notes
and scribbles and failures and everything in
there and then I it's kind of a contained
and searchable
of all the systems if also seems silly to
configure anything need to
that's why I want to just do this once and
get it covered and then I will never have to
you can you imagine how amazing is going to
be I am already so excited I was like having
dreams about it last night because I can I
can provision communities like that like a
real kubernetes block instance and anytime I
want to fuck with a different. He's sitting
or something like that or play with an
offense or or install a sink externally and
then send in my single alerts you know from
you even if it's only thing is running
Docker compose then it from I think I can
actually call out to it and made from fresh
containers to do a single calls I can do
everything I can to know if anything I want
with your daddy's I'm so excited
and people like yeah welcome to the party so
loved answer the workstations
and if sfsf timers
yeah it was an FS was not was not a friend
Center in my dreams but I could have swore I
did a
yeah
if you see kind of local and if that's
that's about this is a fail that was a we
did it but that that was not
that this is what led me to do what I'm
doing now kind kind of you know isn't good
enough
I kind of it just isn't it's not good enough
peanut yellow this is me practicing my TV
mounts
is episode
well if it's set up a set up a ticket system
I bet that's exactly the kind of thing that
we have to sow and if this is the quickest
way to set up you know never attached
storage
for something and it's even if it's a pain
in the ass and everybody agrees it's not the
best way to go
so install NFS benefits Colonel sir it which
is a weird name but that's how you get it
all right so this is why I'm doing this cuz
I got if I got to remember my myself out of
probation this
Siri what's your dash
I want to get so good at sitting in a fess
up I don't even have to think about it I
just just just happens
young yes yes dog shit
Young I have probably go look for a whole
thing on this
lemon FS storage management utils
on
I don't want to configure I want install it
I can read hat
and she exports I don't worry about that 10
how to install
I sent to my state I think
I don't even know that
and then that's just another reason to do it
it's like if you're in a fishing bait stores
that sell then they already
nfsu tills the NFS server packages on
redhead
yeah I don't want to do that I'm sick and I
am I made a really good decision last week
all of my kubernetes work is on redhead
systems
and I'm really glad because it's some of the
stuff is this stuff's already there I don't
think it like right now but it just works
and I'm really glad about that decision
really happy I made that decision
nfsu tells
and start enable and if is Sir and if it's
utils is the name of the package parent Lee
it pops up with that in my provisioning OCC
I'm starting to enable an FS server service
why they call it or PC by never received
mine has an extra part of it yeah
provision n f s
you better necklace and we're fine for you
until now
what does that mean
I am running pop OS I am but I am
provisioning the stuff to run
on my my my environment is going to be
not that
as this record is interesting
I actually don't need to do that but
whatever
I want that to be in there all right
we can move this out into another thing
later alright so we need to do in FS
all right
sudo yum install nfsu tails
and
I see we
we have individual hostnames now so then
we're good we have to have that that's a
really important then what then start the
NFS service
this is why I have to know how to script to
do this job X1 again at this year's
I have a greater percent of those surveyed
are two ways manually adding experts file
using the ex-wife s utility command line I
did not know about export of us utility
maintain table of export in Access file
systems I have a ceramic tea table Etc
nice I do not remember any of that
Central Transport cigarettes fell out like
lights are ignored start a line with hashtag
backslash to rap if I should be on sale
online space characters if any list of
authorized hosts have to be mentioned at for
the office for each of the house should be
placed parentheses directly after those they
didn't fire
it's in the experts file
I guess I might be able this is relatively
easy
I was blocked group will take a second we
will take a secondary disc of your passing
20 GB a Titian this just to create a file
system on it to use as an NFL share
secondary disk
and Princess Anna sister going to file
system on it she's has an NFL sure
I wonder I wonder if I could Frisian extra
volume
I know I can see you forgot how to do it
cuz yeah uh oh
same team, few hours
are you at all that's tricky well that's a
have fun
that's a tough one have you tried talking to
him
may I wouldn't be afraid of talking to
people doing the interview and say I'm on
call that week
I would respect that if you told me that if
I were interviewing you at the interview
gets pissed off by you asking to reschedule
because you're on calling you're doing being
a responsible employee then that's more of a
red flag about your employer a potential
employer the person interviewing you is
actually a good chance to check to check
them out if you say hey I'm sorry I'm on
called that week any other week is fine I
can take it out but that week I'm on call
and I'm unavailable negem Venegas I don't
know I got this guy is so useful and valued
by his current employer we should probably
do what he asks and give him more money for
them
I don't know what I mean
call somebody to sponsor me I get up thank
you for that I got a new $2 a month deposit
is used to say Jesus welcome thank you I see
that you're in there
I see you're there thank you so much for the
sponsorship on GitHub I wish I could notify
you know what I'm going to make a plug that
does that it says notify you Avenue get him
sponsor I'm going to put that in my
streamelements
thank you very much for that I just it's
another reason for me to keep my email up
because it's only when I get notified on
those things
alright alright alright alright so we were
making volumes
are you can make a Des Moines mall by itself
problem is is how do I mount it
and have a system know about it and vagrant
this I do not know Anthony
hey I can have an if statement in here yeah
I can have an if statement in here
that provisions and extra drive as an NFS
Mount and then have it be controlled by
control
is that makes sense I think
will take a secondary disk with capacity of
20 GB and partition this this to create a
file system on it to use as an NFS share
secondary disk and when we see him
I'll see that so say and I don't want them
all to have extra discs
I just want control to have extra discs
I think that's the way to do that
we need a statement here that says
you know if it's a good thing then do
another thing
if my IDs Emissary I have no idea
it's been so long
beginner's guide to Ruby
if name
equals
troll then what
I'll give it an extra 10 GB.
I'll give it a secondary
I don't know what that's going to do this
try it
I had the foresight to just know that's the
Destroyer situation yeah
you take a little while for this base still
faster than it would take if I didn't did do
you want to destroy no to
no no
yes vagrants up
I can say they're the ones are already there
I'm hoping
I asked for the acceleration
work is good
Elmo Lennox 80s
it's just for you for losing control that's
good
and the question is is it going to add the
extra disc or not
not reprovision we allocate rebuild vagrant
totally different tools design for
completely different purposes
vagrant is primarily for bringing up
multiple virtual machines
and doctor is through dealing with
containers
so the only overlap there is the Syracuse
like a workspace container which one is
Lenox looks
Onyx looks appears as if you're using like
you're actually not you're using the
underlying Lennox and vagrant would be a
situation where you want to have multiple
vm's like actual vm's so we have any it we
have this notion of containerization of
virtualization and they cross over sometimes
but there's definitely cases where you want
an actual virtual machine
as much as that sounds like an oxymoron
verb for this exact purpose you cannot run
minikube I tried for a full week to get kind
Docker containers to look like vm's I swam
Upstream try to get that to work if so
stupid I should use Viagra for that
you want to learn kubernetes learned a great
because you can deploy
communities clusters in any number of
different configurations with different
numbers of machines and stuff depending on
how many has CPUs and RAM you have
and it's way better than manacube way better
I'm already like so happy for that
I too was a lot I want to see how many
they going to say control
this is three separate computers that I have
available to me these are not containers
that these are actual virtual machines
Mount what I got a god
I didn't give me the name of the new FS that
we have
so we have the base honest be okay
there we have never move partition
as a room partition have a swap or just
that's what was the stabled Trump should be
disabled
community I think we are away
what is this is just something
I don't think we needed to do it actually I
think at the end of the day we didn't have
to do that
yeah we didn't
if you stand we went through what we went
through all the instructions on how to do
that and turn it didn't need it the one
thing you have to do this is the trickiest
part of container do you versus dr. If this
is first trick the first got you is it you
can't get container D without docker
because you need to add the doctor repo and
that is counterintuitive
but you don't install Docker you only
install container D that I owe that was the
trick
and the third because the default container
D package installation is designed to work
with docker
because it's designed to work with Dr the
default config. Tamil file for container. He
has nothing in it it's like absolutely empty
and so that was in the instructions step by
doing it already can pick default and
sending it out here it takes care of
everything it sets up your proper users and
everything and and then you can just unable
you can you can enable and start container
and it will do still do the right thing and
we we we provisioned so yeah this this this
little bit of magic was not intuitive
because if while exist we open the files and
that makes a file
it appears that the dock of people by
default with container to do not install a
good config. All file because it's designed
to work with Dr right that's where the
package is about but and so you have to say
no I actually want to use container T I want
to override your minimal config file with
the big old The Faults as if I was going to
continue this this is a line of magic fixed
all of that it takes the permissions and fix
the group thing and did all
do that so I'm a super happy about that
because that's I didn't have to set anything
or all that stuff
I am concerned that because I am not seeing
an extra partition
here so
yeah there's no doctor anywhere to be found
on my end points affect how you Doctor it s
or talk about and then somebody somebody
taught me about Kris Kris ETL
somebody tight on Kris ETL and I was like oh
my God
it's so cool you can just crazy tale to do
anything that you would do they would care
about anybody with Doctor you don't need. I
need to increase HDL to replace my doctor's
skills as Dark Arisen as a thing for her
that you're my own you suggested but I don't
think anybody should ever have doctor on
their nose and points anymore and that guy
would strongly encourage you to be removed
to people and abused it
in our Enterprise the admins are abusing
darker bag vlogging it is root on any of the
notes and running Doctor cuz I don't have it
anywhere else cuz it's not on their jump
post their log-in servers and that's bad you
can't convince me
so it doesn't look like it melted I'm
concerned no cuz it does look like it
enabled swapnote I didn't
that's office off
swappa supposed to be off over here
it doesn't look like it's using it so I
think it is off but I don't know how often
is anyway I don't see
this is box storage devices right it should
have given us a different block storage
device
and it did not I miss my if statement didn't
work
this is this is a tough thing because
Vanguard does it end it does magic under the
hood that I don't understand and don't need
to understand I need to just do it
I'm going to actually try this I said let's
read about disc allocation
vagrant
I want to add an extra just volume to cuz if
you look at role playing
the real primary true
sometimes it is the primary just for I guess
is not large enough and you need to add more
space to resize adjust you can simply add a
config like this below to expand the size of
your guests arrive
eraser
no the furniture this is telling me her to
expand the guest main drive without this
option bigger ones that attach a new disc
to the guest
we have the event to get some now come with
right I think my if statement is it is the
fail here
that I don't know if that's true or not I
want an extra 10 GB try that
I'm going to try to do vagrant
does Riley want to destroy the control plane
yes it's Joy. Imma try to reprovision it and
see if it pulls the next thing up otherwise
then I'll go check my recent texts
so excited about this you have no idea
I've been wanting this for more than a year
a happy release
this this is the one true way the one true
waited to take as long as you cooperate I
swear to God and I've seen other extremely
experienced can race people on YouTube that
are very esoteric had no followers do the
same thing
so I feel that that's been confirmed for me
but once again I'm going to go make coffee
corn braids going down the wrong pipe
all right all right
please let me have a new can I has a new
volume
are you liking the expertise
if it stops rather abruptly cuz we got to
network I don't know what to do I don't know
how to teach you
so every year it gets better hopefully I'll
have all of them
the rest of you don't know
the last two years I've been doing beginner
boost series it's very very very very casual
is it going to get you going
and I'm getting ready to going to be doing
everything I've been learning about
communities or last year I'm going to try to
put that into 26-week Series in preparation
for my certification I'm going for in June
and I don't get it but I'm going to go for
it
everybody says I should do fine but I don't
know nothing
there's a video that experts use talking
about alright so
if this is a thing we should be able to log
into the control plane and see LS block we
should have to block devices
and we don't we still only have the one damn
it
how do I make more than one block device
I'm out of my league here with a red he's I
mean with vagrants so I'm going to go go to
the internet's
I promise you for example a bunch of guests
will now come with her to get some juice
rather than the fault
anniversary box
I didn't have her to box functions it is not
possible to shrink the size of disc weren't
using where to buy shoes in the liver make a
can attach multiple disks to a gas using her
I got bull this is what we want
I can pick me up to find hatch corn to blah
name extra storage
lyric an attachment with this suggests using
you're the best writer the example of
attaching a single this to a guest with 10
GB or should be down here
that's a good name I bet I do I bet I do I
bet I have to get a different name
yeah I bet that's it
and say name
Anna Faris
vagrant destroy control and what are you and
already restarted yes please
vagrants up control
we can figure this out we will really be off
and running will have a lot of advantages
that this works pressure involvement what a
name
Russian velvet 7381 the name that's a great
name to
Dave poggi
it's all good
covid-19
that reminds me of like home so I didn't
know Maha I'm sure you do
sun Saudia is the Sun
the chant the chant to the sun in South
Street is home so yeah, ha
I want to see Ryan Omaha
so if you want to worship the Sun or you
want to worship somebody named santiso
yachty
I'm sorry Anna Maha
running the script. Is that the region is
here that It Go
please Let There be two discs let there be
light and two discs here
adding an extra volume is not something you
can do from inside of the OS obviously it's
like Hardware you have to say
Imma Stay revelation
turn turn into dual complete
shoe all right
please have another one dammit no success
is it that I just can't see it it's a box
but it's a box devices should be there right
now
I don't know what's going on it's not
working
and it didn't give the name or anything I
failed I have failed
I think of a new extra storage when we do
wrong to do something wrong we didn't do
anything wrong it's just
I think I might name and invest can you only
have one
maybe have to put it up here I wonder if
this disk in line is even being read at all
I don't want to get them all extra disc
10th is peace
Shante is peace and stability is Sun so it's
probably your name probably means peaceful
son
I don't I don't know what I'm doing I have
to go read more a lot I need to read other
stuff
I'm thinking we need to touch it to if you
touch many this you can you read me to
generate multiple discs for vagrant attached
to your guests
and if I had scored youdo I
this didn't work I tried this
what am I missing am I missing something I
feel like this is right
I feel like that's right
it only works is virtualbox are you sure
if that's true that would explain it
I'm afraid that means that I'm going to need
to mount the main volume of control as an FS
mount on it and everything else
as I'm going to have to do this which isn't
that bad that's on the bad me for what we're
doing and I think that's fine
so it's only wears a box I do I've
encountered my first
example of something that does not work and
that's the first time
I could change it to I could change all of
this to Mel Let's test that hypothesis yummy
let's do let's change it to
I'm trying to surprise you with something
I just want to this is this is an academic
exercise
alright so let's try it I mean pull down the
whole thing
and I have a box on here so I can provision
everything over too much and then I want to
see if I get it if I get an extra Mount
point
I mean cuz at the end of the day I really
don't care how much extra overhead is
virtualbox from liver by the way
you know what I mean this is this is
something that I really can't measure
after all the hassle I had to go through to
get liver to work
I kind of wonder if I should just kick it to
the curb and just use virtualbox tell me why
I will laugh his ass off because that's what
he said I was going to end up doing
give me a second
I hate that that's true you know what a
virtual box allows me to use multiple
volumes and liver doesn't
my short walk to get coffee has given me
time to ponder the decision
and I'm quite certain
that I will not be using the word any
further if that's true
let me tell you why as efficient and awesome
as liver is on a single system for Linux
there's two there's two factors that have
played into this decision to move to
virtualbox from delivered and chemo
the first factor is
somebody suggesting that I publish my my
vagrant set up so that other people can do
training
on whatever system they have and
if I go public it's going to be clear that
most people are going to have much easier
time sitting up virtualbox by just fucking
installing it just works right that's the
first reason the second reason
is that you can mount a multiple Bloxorz
devices and you can test situations where
you emulate having multiple multiple core it
if you cannot emulate a virtual machine that
has multiple this tribe's than what the fuck
is the point
and if liver doesn't allow you to do that
then that is not that is not a proper
solution because I I need to be able to test
scenarios where I have a system that has
extra space attached or doesn't have a base
attached turn used to measure the Nexus
baseball a month and that's a real core
requirement for any other reasons I would
never use a virtual machine the first place
with this kind of stuff so
that's going to make a decision pretty solid
and I will document that conclusion if this
turns out to be the true so there's a Moment
of Truth vagrant SSH
control we should see 22 block storage
devices here and we do not wish means I'm
still doing it wrong
it means I'm still doing it wrong what am I
doing wrong
that's actually encouraging because it's
possible it liver it still does it
wait what why is this reporting 128 gig disc
from this up with your studies and liver
provider oh you know why
because I have the environment variable set
of it you know I explicitly said virtualbox
very interesting yeah I have a feeling it's
not a very well I'm using
they are in default provider
let me make sure first of all
yeah that's weird hey presidents and
apparently they did
I found a few likes scientists and
physicists how I don't know
I don't have a lot I recently was made aware
of therecently was made aware of the of the
Danish
I want to say the Danish word dutch that the
person who had and who who discovered
quantum physics
that's the best probably my favorite
physicist right now most because everybody
thought they were fucking insane and then
ended up being completely dry and then
getting totally Vindicated and and that's
why I think I like them the most I I need to
figure out who that was they were studying
the behavior of light photons Niels Bohr
yeah that's him
knows where I actually want to read it a lot
more about Niels Bohr
I don't know anything about him as a bunch
of this mess a computer scientist kind of
people that are that I really like to but
I'm all the scientists the one that comes to
my mind first is Niels Bohr mostly because
of all the shit he took
everybody thought he was insane they told
him his crazy Einstein directly the big
fucking marketing power that which was
Einstein took full power attack against
Niels Bohr and said you're full of shit I'm
going to prove it and use all of it in a
scientific marketing and budget powered is
thing to disprove bore and he's into being
wrong and he died Einstein died regretting
his greatest regret was you couldn't
dibrunos Moore was right was wrong and Niels
Bohr just quietly one
I just I really that's why I like him so
much
Roy system isn't working for 7 Robin I have
to go outside I have to do something else I
have to force myself to do something else
away
but absolutely I feel like I'm in prison
this is my prison right here is a stupid
fucking apartment why you think I might wear
so motivated to buy another car because I
don't got got in the shop because we got
rear-ended by a semi my wife on a slowly
thank God
so then I can get out of here and get out of
here and go walk around I actually was like
so many people I don't like
I like control and like working with
computers by the way I really love it I like
Simon plumbing problems but it's not built
in to be more of an outdoors person and so
I've had to come to terms that the very very
hard
good answer he actually no shit
yeah there's actually really great
documentary on that I mean it's it's very
sensationalised for the sake of the other,
if you were on Netflix or prime I think it
is Amazon Prime but it was a win in the
quantum and then it got into it it was
really cool
I wish I knew his name now they'll remember
his name or that's why I like Barb workout
you know you got shit on
I really miss my bicycle Community officer
about yo yeah me too oh God yeah I wish I
could do that I did that for 20 years
no I did it it felt like I did it for why
were you so frightened so that's three years
in and I can do it for 3 years
and after that I just work from home I work
from home for 25 years after that or the
twenty or so after that from always the
difference is I don't have my bike with me
because his fucking apartment is there
supposed to be transitioning to a house and
now we're stuck here
Tesla summer rain is crazy yeah he's a super
popular it's like it's like it's like it's
like all the hackers loving Che Guevara was
awesome but he was also
not awesome she's a he still wanted some of
the shirts
at my favorite are the I like it on the song
Heroes Immokalee is like a really big fear
Sciences II you guys rented. I DM digital
computer and then you have all that the
people in this shit in there have you rent a
Fanta have you read the innovators
I'm only about halfway into it I need to get
I need to finish it I really need to finish
it you might like it it's pretty interesting
it's it's it's an Isaac since it's about the
right decisions
is it supposed to always wanted to make you
says it's like a book that covers a lot of
innovators who makes fantastic but he's done
some of the things as well he's writing his
and research is just so phenomenal it's it's
a
I've been tempted I've been actually I've
been tempted to read this one on stream
the innovators Walter Isaacson so he goes
through everybody touring and all this the
reason I really love it
the reason I really love it though is he
covers a bunch of like unsung heroes that
were literally working as front room you
know when makgeolli came around and still
oh you're going to love it if you like this
kind of his sister and stuff Paul Erdos I
don't know about Paul I'm not bad good
well ready for the Philippines I don't know
about that makes me want to read about it I
love biographies by the way. Turning is King
he definitely is I was going to say to ring
and that's when I went to check my computer
scientists returning is
yeah he's definitely up there of course but
you know I think babbage's entertaining the
whole the whole day after they both got
there like Silicon Valley mentality before
there was Silicon Valley mentality they had
like start of sickness before there was a
star of sickness thing so if you can't do
anything without me I'm your I am I am your
shining Beacon it's so good that the
correspondence between Babbage and Ada and
it is like I'm not coming to work for you
and less you put me as credit in this and
you suck without me you know you need me
every time everybody thinks it'll ever see
that picture of her and that nice pretty
dress cuz she's the daughter of Lord Byron
right now she's a badass but she was also
very not polite
if you're both such people draw quickly I
did they draw conclusions about you know
which historical figures from the picture
and then they they don't even I didn't even
get it they were Babbage Babbage and Aiden
are having all kinds of shit go down that
was very much the kind of shit you would
hear and still kind of I probably imagined
you would have never been so I imagine that
you would hear in Silicon Valley today why
do likewise
I ain't like Linus Torvalds a lot right
because I don't know he just does what he
wants and he's right and he doesn't
apologize
he has a lot of I mean there's a lot of
there's a lot of Personality failures that
he has that I share I think maybe that's why
the reason I like him
I mean you know he's he's definitely not a
shining Beacon of you know how to behave but
he's also brilliant so I value that more I
would rather he I would rather Torvalds like
call me a back birth and at least
acknowledge my existence then to receive
praise from a lesser human being that's just
me I but I'm built differently that's how I
am I I'm not I can take it I don't you know
Davis yeah
yeah people talked about him a lot he still
has a channel here somewhere
if he was he was a good programmer addicted
to mess
is it okay so we are going to try to get to
see the right thing so
we are where are we
I don't need to rejuvenate provisioning
don't need that I need to clean up a little
bit.
I want to need around this is I don't know
who married me
I probably don't need to have this open I do
need these open now
this is it same as for Ruby
at work to come back to the same as cuz I
think that they might work I think the
problem it wasn't working before was because
of the the provisioner provider
that's not supposed for Emeryville time now
that's very sweet of you seen the source
code for Minecraft it's absolute shit no
sorry not if you're watching but oh my God
what he would tell you that you'll be the
first person to tell you that it's like dude
I was playing around with Java I was an
experiment
is
not pretty much all of them are autistic son
plus I'm now they're all on the Spectrum I'm
pretty sure I am on the Spectrum
oh yeah that just happens everybody though
name a name like one person who doesn't
degrade because I have lots of money and
it's pretty much everyone
so we need to get rid of that
what's thesunset vagrants
call provider alright service due destroy
the toy the toy this please I want to
destroy them all
a first name your child that I did not
finish it or not not to be the first person
to tell you that the source code for
Minecraft is she said you'd be the first one
to say so
he was experimenting you said this is a fun
program I just want to see if it works he
just kept adding more crafts to do it over
and over and there's nothing wrong with it
I'm not putting down a notch
I mean he did kind of he did kind of you
know
that dude had to do a lot of shit though
people sent death threats man yeah we ever
heard about that
he had nothing to do with the purchase was
Minecraft or any of the other changes and
people would send him deathreats all the
time he hadn't worked on Minecraft for like
five six years he was off doing that other
thing he was working on right and people
would send a difference cuz I guess I'm
going to kill you because you ruined my
Minecraft like my gown is just a fucking
game
it's crazy I know wondering you probably
already was going to reclusive and then all
the sudden all these humans come out and
prove how much he hates humans
you know how many of us are are sometimes
subject to that I would be me sometimes I
hate all humanity and then I meet people
like you all and it restores my faith in
humanity in like know there's people in my
wife thank God for my wife oh my God thank
God for my wife
from your life love you big we write about a
bunch of Santa Maria writing a bunch of a
bunch of mods and stuff
you one of the many it been many very
intelligent successful engineer start with
Minecraft some of them are millionaires now
you can watch that that's that's featured in
the vice documentary cyberwar where there is
a millionaire based on software he wrote to
prevent attacks against his Minecraft
servers became a millionaire and he says the
words Minecraft making some pretty good
Engineers out there he said it just like
that
I need to get that quote I need to go I need
to go to watch the entire cyber World Series
again and just like and just like getting
video video clip after video clip out of it
and there's so many good video clips in it
yeah he moved yes he did
yes he did does that make him a bad person
you tell me I don't know
I don't know who mocks is
I don't know I'm a hermit I don't know who
that is
I don't am I supposed to know I have a
better feeling about this one it just feels
it feels better
I hate that I'm going to have to throw a
live bird out after doing all that fucking
work whatever at least I can say I know live
right now
oh you haven't been around for the last week
yeah that was there were several episodes
between then and now and now I'm a big big
enough and I've apologized for everything I
said about vagrant at least five times at
this point
I was wrong I was wrong it was delivered
that was the problem it wasn't bigger
Moxie genius you have to find Moxie I don't
I have never heard of them they probably a
wonderful streamer I don't know
single is awesome
still no discs I guess I'm kind of getting
pissed now
if there's a burning to be pissed
why does it keep making making love bird
stuff
all right I'm going to rip you the fuck out
I'm going to rip you out
picking latest
oh I think it pays off yeah
I didn't did the problems libert, say that
again the problem that I had with vagrant
wasn't vagrants fault it was delivered and
it was because the liver provider for Vegas
is not very good
and now I'm realizing why because I run into
my first reason for not using live bird at
all
yeah I make bigger and got my routes and
didn't deserve it what else is new right
all right when I force it to do you know
what I think it is I think
I think vagrant uses liver unless you
explicitly tell it not to
and it's got the other one just got someone
that's over at Minecraft now right I mean at
Microsoft I get that right
very big lunch box my channel ID
I want this to work
that's what I've been told I've read that
and I've been told that now so as soon as
testing
how's everything if indeed that is true
make a box of Puffs invented there is a Xbox
a Xbox it's a lie just like for some boxes
buggy yeah but if virtualbox definitely is
buggy but it first box lets you do a
separate block storage devices nnn liver
does not we don't know that yet but if
that's true then that's a no-brainer that's
a no-brainer and I'll never use Levert again
for vagrant if that's true
so that's what we're experimenting with
right now in case you're wondering I'm
trying to decide if I can bring up a
separate block storage device and I should
do I should probably do a new thing here
I should make a new lab for this I should
make loud that explained that explores the
difference the different favorite files
what time is my meeting
all right I have a I have a 2:30 meeting I
have to go to
subtitles in English you just need to go
watch the videos I did about it
yeah I made a YouTube video about how to add
subtitles it's on youtube.com rwx Rob
pretty good so far I can't forget I have a
meeting at 2:30 I cannot forget that meeting
I need to make I'm going to make a new lid
for a new library for comparing providers
and I'm going to say okay this one is using
virtualbox in this one is not and I want to
I'm going to I'm going to confirm that one
is allows block additional block storage
devices it's just like a big deal
what are you do I read it twice that says
that's the case but I want to get it so that
that's confirmed you know
just set a timer yeah I just something I do
the same thing thanks for the
I think thanks for the reminder
Remind me at 2:30 I have a meeting thank you
I'm so grateful I gave up on my privacy just
so I can ask for reminders
and this is a provisioning three systems I
didn't need to do this so I got to be like
Econo Tampa command repo so I'm going to the
one in the car if I say
I saw the look on one of The Wonder Years
I would install whatever one's right in
front of you go just looks gorgeous looks
right to the stuff that's right there
please work god dammit
delivery going to be pissed why does it keep
making livered commit stuff
do I need to set up a different provisioner
I am confused all right time for a new test
I'm sorry I got 15 minutes I can do this
time for new test
live vagrants
storage compare
that's a huge one but I don't care I don't
care
are they grants either a storage
all right so we can make a bigger file
no we don't want to do this video vague
friends Annette
just call it a day vagrant
no
I want that bass no we're going to do
generic
Alma 8 dark Saturday to checks network box
port forwarding
that we can be him alright so
lab kids
vagrant I can file
actually I just do the whole thing
fuk fuk
Meghan file home
yeah
vagrant is for provisioning VM is for
Developers
so they can test different things as if they
were on different machines you don't complex
environments
Xbox
wait I don't want this one cuz I don't need
all that shit when do
I'm going to make a fool
alright let's try this
am I the man still there I think they still
are oh shit
tripping out of resources oh no we just
haven't
we're going to kick it off live right now
it's like I can't spend all that time
getting on liver and I can't get off of it
what the fuck what is that
I don't think that's something that would be
cool if it was
I don't know
I don't know I don't know
yeah but I mean when I shouldn't have to do
that
I mean I'm at the whole point of this is to
say that I don't have to do that right
God it's like how explicit do I have to get
let's try that for the sake of
I mean yeah it if it doesn't work
well there you go well there you go
Let it go I need to put that in his head
I said I have I have both of those and
neither of them took but because it was an
error
it just whatever when I can find but I
didn't know that
so then I got this
yeah watch him you want to see something
cool check this
I need to put this command I'm going to run
it with a run this command in vim and
replace it with the output of the command
without doing any cutting and pasting you're
ready so bang bang that's the filter command
to send a current line to the command line
she'll run it in bash and replace it with
its output
damn it's too smart for me is too smart for
a God damn it
that's right again but not like it did let's
just let's say
and every time I make a big deal about
something it doesn't work so fuck that
everybody they turn up
Idaho I got delivered but I'm trying to tell
you is you can actually run shit apparently
vagrant is too smart for me
this is probably getting sense that out
actually
so this particular case is going to be the
hard way
I'm going down here and use this
I did destroy the Box I did this red
and sacrifice makes your birthday I just
read it many many times I halted it I
destroyed it I did all that it didn't do it
so the reason is right here vagrant could
not detect virtualbox another was virtualbox
is it installed have a feeling this is the
reason I have a confirm yet
at 5 minutes okay 6 minutes
Why didn't it make any noise it should have
been noise for me it didn't
every two boxes of cell please find the VX
Mary added to the bath
Remax manage binary yes
if there is a cinder path so I don't know
what's up
I don't know what's up with that really
don't
Afghanistan the call that's like really lame
yeah I'm going to get on the call and I'm
going to go I'm going to have to meet though
wait
yeah yeah I'll be back
all right that's that's off yeah
yeah I don't know this I think there's
something walking up the KVM to give him
stuff and it's not saying it there's no way
to know that though so
let me try to do a by hand so
vagrant
Levert again why does it keep using
delivered
a grant the strawberries that I'll trade and
plug in the flesh
are sinking rsync shit that's cool
I move the bigger in files
big friends list sorry status
not created
Liberty again I don't know why I keep
driving with vert
I'm annoyed
can't do it
absolutely know that it's in the path so
this is some bug
I don't know what the bug is but it's
definitely a bug cuz it's in the path that's
not a problem
you know what else is new right
ironically I defense so much work to get
liver to run that if I undo the work I did I
might I risk
and I'm not being able to get liver back
easily have it all documented but still
Justice for sister to realize that I can't
do multiple multiple block devices with
virtualbox despite the stuff I've read and
heard from the trap
I haven't think if I reboot it will reset
because Liberty won't be turned on by
default
and I might fix first box
I mean it could be the result boxes like
hoes to I can't even type anything
because papa is a piece of shit power off
off off
has beenhas been released, said let's do a
fresh virtualbox install habitat
the song be fine update
I can't see that
it's raining now and then work on virtualbox
upgrade which might kick out the vert might
also fail because you can't get control of
our provider I think that's what's happening
we had that same problem before yes
Halo strips at price of generic Xanax do you
say I'm saying I think I think that but the
hypervisor is fucked up the KVM is not as
messed up at the moment and somebody else's
is using it I thought there was a way to
look at who was using it as a Caprock see if
groups or something like that
Amish can reboot I'll see you in a bit